[Music]
one particularly interesting and
important character in ursula k le guin
sixth earth sea novel the other wind is
king lebanon formerly called aaron who
we saw as a main character in the third
earth c novel where he's with ged uh
trying to solve the crisis of earth sea
and then showing up again in the fourth
earth sea novel where he is now a young
king this is 15 years into his kingship
he's had some time to mature and
most importantly
for a very important political
institution
to arise in fact to be
put together by him as part of his
rulership and what this is reflective of
is a certain kind of
leadership a certain model that lebanon
is not the only person to follow in
laguin's earthsea universe but which he
perhaps
exemplifies
to the highest extent and this is
something that we see in the council of
rock we see this also in a few other
places and this this model of leadership
is one that
takes in perspectives of others
expressed by them and then they're
debated
and the valuable ideas are incorporated
you sift them out over time and then you
have somebody who's a final decision
maker and this works if you actually
have somebody who is a king or in our
time you know in a company a ceo
somebody who will make the final
decision it's a collaborative way of
deciding things but one that also still
has a executive who will
cast the final and deciding vote you
could say and this is very important for
a number of reasons it allows people to
feel as if they have a stake as if
they've been
heard
whether they are or not we'll talk about
that in just a moment
and it allows you to benefit from
the ideas of others which they might not
express to you if they don't think
that you will take them seriously and we
see that lebanon
does this really throughout his entire
career
and there are some instances of less
formal what we can call council taking
as a matter of fact it's actually called
that at one point and i'll just give you
a few examples of it these are
discussions that occur
and this is how we see lebanon working
at things so you know for example
there's this discussion that takes place
where alder is involved
tahanu
theroux
the king
and so you know we see this this
discussion that that goes on onyx is
involved in it
prince edge is involved in a tulsa is
involved and so they're talking and
alder says if i'm a plague bringer you
must send me away and the wizard onyx
spoke if rogue sent you to gantt and god
sent you to have nor hovnor is where you
should be so roque is the the wizards
the council there the masters and they
send
him to ged
there on gant and ged hears his story
listens to what the the masters had to
say and i said well you go over to
hovnor and by the way take some messages
for me to my my daughter tahani and
they'll sort matters out there or at
least try to figure them out and then
tulsa says
many heads make light thinking this is a
perfect
example
an encapsulation
of what's going on in this model many
heads make light thinking it becomes
easier to think when you have people
in good will without trying to bring in
their own agendas and you know cause
conflict or anything like that thinking
through things together
and so then lebanon says
let's put dreams aside for a while our
guest needs to know what we were
concerned about before he came why i
begged tenar and tahanu to come earlier
this summer and summon tosla from his
voyaging you know here we see the term
to take counsel with us will you tell
alder of this matter tulsa and then
tulsa talks about the dragon so that you
know there's several different crises
taking place everybody is being brought
into discussion of these if they're you
know if they have something to
contribute
another uh example
is where we see
this
discussion this reference to
council as well taking council that
evening before with his advisers and
officers of his guard
lebanon had quickly concluded there was
no way to fight the dragons or protect
the towns and fields from them arrows
were useless shields were useless only
the greatest mages had ever been able to
defeat a dragon he had no such mage in
his service and knew of none now living
but he must defend his people as best he
could and
he knew no way to do it but to try to
parlay with the dragons so what does he
do he takes counsel with the advisors
and officers on this particular matter
where they are competent and then he
comes to his own conclusions about it so
these are some prime examples of how
lebanon
thinks through problems then we find a
whole discussion of the king's council
there's about you know
two pages or so about this political
institution that leguin
is narrating which is quite interesting
so
he's uh she says into that stern and
high beamed hall on a cool morning of
late summer sea fog
filed the king's council
91 men and women 100 if all had been
there so this is a pretty substantial
body
of people a hundred representatives
and we find out that they have all been
chosen by the king which leads you know
some people a little bit later to say
that here we go
there were those who said the council
was nothing but the king's pets and
puppets
but that doesn't seem to be the case
certainly from the depiction that we
have and the representatives are very
broadly chosen so there's a great
discussion here
some represent the great noble and
princely houses of the inner isles
pledged vassals of the crown so we've
got nobility involved
some to speak for the interests of other
islands and parts of the archipelago
so all the other parts are being
represented as well it's not just a
central islands versus the reaches or
something like that they're being
represented
some because the king had found them or
hoped to find them useful and
trustworthy counselors of state some are
being chosen on the basis of talent or
potential
some uh there he says there are
merchants shippers factors of hovnor and
the other great port cities of the sea
of asia in the inmost sea
so that's
quite important as well the merchant the
economic class is being represented then
he goes on he says there were masters
from the workers guilds
flexible uncanny bargainers
among them a pale eyed hard-handed woman
the chief of the miners of oskill
mining we find out in a much earlier
story is largely a woman's art in
earthsea so it's not just the
business owners and the
commerce people that are represented
it's also
the
workers through their guilds there's
others as well there were rogue wizards
like onyx there was also a pelnish
wizard called master sepal
so you know the magic users are being
represented there were noble women young
and old from the kingdoms thieves and
principalities and two island women
stout plain and dignified one from ifish
one from corp to speak for the people of
the east reach
there were even some poets some learned
people from the old colleges of aya and
the enlares and
several captains of soldiery or of the
king's ship so this is is this
representing every single person in
earth sea no but this is a very broadly
representative council
where there's going to be a lot of
useful perspectives and what do they do
they have arguments and debates about
the matters
and it's interesting because
he says
all laws and taxations all judgments
brought before the throne he
discussed with them taking their counsel
so
every matter of state every matter of
taxation every you know
sort of high level decision that is
being made the council
is part of it
and this is very important this is very
different than how earthsea had been led
by you know the many people who weren't
kings but were lords or things like that
prior to that
so he says they
here's how it runs they would then vote
on his proposal and only with the
consent of the majority was it enacted
so this is also an important feature
they they vote on these things the king
does get his way
at a number of points but the council
are the ones who are voting
we read he mostly got his way if he
argued for it often he expressed no
opinion and let the council make the
decision
many counselors had found if they had
enough facts to support their opposition
and made a good argument they might sway
the others and even persuade the king so
debates within the various divisions and
special bodies were often hotly
contested even in full session the king
had several times been opposed argued
with and voted down
so
lebanon is choosing
not to be an authoritarian ruler and
even to allow himself to be overruled
when
arguments can be made when evidence can
be brought forward and when the rest of
the council or at least a majority of
them
can be convinced of the rightness of
this decision as opposed to
this decision
now that's a very
uh enlightened way of proceeding
probably also a rather effective way as
well
and there's some effects to this
as leguin points out the people of power
respect the council
right
he found the council served him well
people of power had come to respect it
so this gets buy-in this gets
participation
from all the other people who might be
tempted to hold back
or to resist in some way
it's producing a collaborative model of
of decision making for the entirety of
earth c minus of course the the realm of
the kargs
and the common people though
interestingly enough they don't care
about this that's leguin says
common people did not pay much attention
to the council they're not involved with
it right
they center their hopes and attention on
the king's person
so this is you know
understandable and she talks about it in
terms of what we would nowadays call
media there were a thousand lays and
ballads about the son of morid the
prince who rode the dragon back from
death to the shores of day
et cetera et cetera but it was hard
going to make songs about councillors
debating shipping taxes
so
you know the common people are less
interested in what the council is doing
but lebanon is really relying on this
council as a continuing institution he
selects the council members they're
appointed for you know several years and
then he either sends them on their way
or you know replaces them with somebody
new or keeps them in place to continue
on
they have a
representative uh council
meeting where we see the issue of the
dragons being debated and the question
then is what they ought to do
he gives them information right
he told them and it was for many it was
the first real news of these matters
about the dragon's attacks on west
havnor how he had set out with the woman
of god tahana to parley with them
and um finally he told them what had
happened at the pass
in the following mountains at dawn three
days ago
and that orm erium is is coming back and
then they begin to discuss well
what do you hope to gain by parley with
a dragon and as it turns out a lot of
the council are a little bit big for
their britches and think well we can
fight these dragons they're you know we
we've got the technology we've got the
tools we've got the bravery and then you
know lebanon is like no you're not going
to be able to do that and the wizard
says you you don't know what you're
talking about and this is how these sort
of debates work right and then the
question turns to a different one okay
so if we're not gonna fight them then
who should speak shouldn't it be you
wizards this is what the the non-uh
magic users are saying
and eventually they get to the point
where um first is it's explained by the
wizards that you can't really change
into a dragon and stay that way for a
while but also that there is one among
us who need use no art and can speak for
us to dragons better than any man could
do if she will speak to us and tahanu
says i will
and that brought pause to discussion for
a minute soon they were all at it again
the king listened and did not speak now
notice this this line he wanted to know
the temper of his people he wanted to
know what the people are
thinking finally it's the noon time and
they declare a recess into the first
hour of the afternoon and we don't get
to see what would happen with a council
meeting because
ormerian
arrives and now it's time to actually
begin the parliament so no decision was
actually taken
but we got to see how the
decision-making
and deliberation takes place
by looking at an actual instance of it
so in a way this is very interesting le
guin is giving us
both
theory and
practice an application
for this imaginary institution within
this narrative world
of earthsea of a properly functioning
king's council so this is really
quite an interesting feature of the work
and lebanon himself fits in with this
quite well because it matches his model
of decision making and leadership
you